Cuáles son las implicaciones
puntualmente para Colombia y Guatemala
como ustedes de estos nuevos centros de
solicitudes migratorias harán que
migrantes de países más al sur en el
Continente lleguen primero a estas
naciones para realizar el procesamiento
el procesamiento
lo que lo que incluye será para primero
es una revisión sobre los méritos de
cada persona no significa que todos van
a calificar para un procesamiento de
refugio en otro país pero significa que
se les dará información a cada persona
que llegue estos lugares algo muy
importante y preciso sobre esto es que
una persona para tener acceso a estos
centros tendrá que primero solicitar una
una cita para llegar a después
informarse sobre sus posibilidades para
los países de Colombia Guatemala lo que
esto significa es que va a ser una
posible agenda más de poder apoyar a más
migrantes pero también con eso conlleva
más recursos y necesidades para poder
dar que esas personas tengan solamente
sus solicitudes pero también servicios
afuera los centros ya que este tipo de
Procedimientos suele tomar en lo a lo
mucho semanas para poder empezarlo y
también puede llegar a tener un poco más
de meses si es que se puede completar
desde ese centro y hasta este momento ya
Estados Unidos ha anunciado apoyos para
Colombia para Guatemala para realizar y
para implementar estos estos centros de
procesamiento de solicitudes
la intención del gobierno de Estados
Unidos en este momento es empezar con
5.000 casos al día o bueno que Disculpen
el mes para tener cada en este lugar en
cada centro tener una oportunidad de
poder apoyar a ese número de personas
los que van a apoyar en el servicio será
acnur y oim que se encargarán de de
poder dar al proceso diario de las de
los solicitudes pero también con
recursos de Estados Unidos todavía no se
dice qué tanto dinero se va a poder
aportar o qué más se podría despedir del
gobierno cubano colombiano guatemalteco
o otro en el futuro pero lo importante
en este caso es que será principalmente
agencias internacionales que se
encarguen sobre las operaciones de este
centro qué pasa con países como España y
Canadá que anunciaron que recibirán
algunos migrantes que criterios se van a
implementar
para Canadá y para España lo que más se
ha interesado es en llevar a cabo
procesos para
vincular las personas con visas de
trabajo a Canadá o a España Canadá tiene
ya una historia muy amplia sobre dar
Refugio a personas que también lo
solicitan a lo mejor puede ser esa otra
oportunidad pero para España
principalmente se les darán
oportunidades a las personas que tienen
algún Familiar o si no alguna
oportunidad de trabajar en este caso en
ese país puede cambiar en otros países
puede ser que después haya un centro en
Panamá o en Costa Rica o en México y en
cada país se va a poder abrir un poco un
no solamente estos rutas pero también
otros posibles avenidas que cada
gobierno puede probar Como por ejemplo
protección complementaria en México
mallorcase en su anuncio Indicó que no
hay planes de tener a familias en la
frontera que la intención es implementar
alternativas a estas detenciones A qué
se refiere
alternativas a las usualmente las
familias que llegan a la frontera de
Estados Unidos se les da por ejemplo un
brazalete o un celular para que después
de que sean procesados en la frontera y
lleguen a su destino sean Nueva York
Miami o otra ciudad en Estados Unidos
puedan seguir llevando a cabo su
supervisión con la con los agencias de
migración las cuales determinarán si se
pueden quedar en el país o no Esto será
lo que ha sucedido en el pasado y espero
que siga lo que sucede en el futuro pero
si estas personas importantes este caso
si estas familias sean rechazadas sus
suspensiones sobre asilo serán entonces
repatrias a sus países de origen lo que
antes no sucedía tan frecuentemente